you know I'm not gonna lie I am a sucker
for the song but there is an
ever-increasing irony that the original
theme for this franchise was simple and
clean given that you can't sum up the
plot without an hour and a flowchart so
this was actually something that was has
always been on the short list of things
for me to talk about for why it's
awesome which is just my series of me
rambling about stuff that I love whether
it's topical or not but suddenly this
became topical because something I
thought might never happen actually
happened which is Kingdom Hearts 3 came
out I haven't played it I can't play it
I don't have a system that'll play it
but I was always planning to talk about
Kingdom Hearts 1 & 2 cuz it played those
and I love them now full disclosure I
have not kept up with the Kingdom Hearts
series for a couple of reasons one of
them practical they have kept they
started dropping and trees on systems I
didn't have I did I never had a 3ds so I
forget which one that was the Mac came
out so like the ones that I've actually
played all the way through r12 and chain
of Memories everything else after that I
think my other problem is I was working
off the old model where the numbered
entries in the series were the important
ones anything else was a spinoff and not
stuff you necessarily needed to know and
apparently that's where all the plot has
been happening and the plot is wow it's
kind of become a punchline but I really
don't want to focus on that I want to go
back to that original game Kingdom
Hearts came with a pitch both brilliant
and insane with its simplicity
Disney final fantasy together in a game
I'm sorry what like that that's weird
and bizarre and like there's no way that
should work like that should be the most
ridiculous thing ever and on top of it
your lead characters aren't gonna be
from either franchise but a set of
original characters who don't connect to
anything else so we're doing a massive
crossover yet
inserting original characters into it
why does this work well part of it is
the execution of the idea and some of it
is actually the secret genius of the
idea itself so execution-wise that first
game was just for the time especially
not sure it's aged great a lot of stuff
from sort of that era as it's showing
its age but it was visually really well
done it was terrifically designed
cutscenes were great the voice acting
was amazing music was awesome it was fun
to play which is always kinda key to all
these things and in the initial game at
least the story was Wow a little bit
nonsensical not convoluted now when I
mentioned it the intrinsic secret
brilliance of the concept here's what I
mean by that so the structure of that
original game and also Kingdom Hearts 2
and from what I gather Kingdom Hearts 3
as well but again haven't played it is
that you're just moving from Disney
World to Disney World and helping the
heroes and defeating the fill-ins
the villains of that Disney setting now
on the one hand you think well boy
that's cheesy as heck but there was
something that I realized while playing
it and the main reason I got into it was
I just kind of at the time I found
Square Enix to be very reliable they'd
made most of my meanwhile dating back to
when they were just Squaresoft they had
made most of my favorite games at that
point so I was willing to give it a shot
so the thing is that sort of general
concept of the heroes working their way
through a grander story and saving
certain characters certain areas as they
go along
is fairly typical that's not an atypical
structure for an RPG ish kinda game of
the time but the thing is most of the
time as you're doing that you're only
investment is your own character maybe
in you know the villain that you're
chasing down or you know whatever is the
recurring stuff you generally don't get
invested in the individual settings that
you're in for a little while to save
some local whoever from the regional
kobold nest or whatever but you drop
them in you drop the player into a
Disney setting something they grew up
with something they have nostalgia for
and it immediately gives you a much
higher level of investment of what would
otherwise be just the latest grinding
zone because you know I actually I
remember having the worst sinking
feeling in that first game when there
was the section set in 100 Acre Woods I
went oh no you are not gonna threaten
winnie-the-pooh no I will defend this
wood to my dying breath because I have
inherent investment emotional commitment
baggage already tied up in these
characters and it makes it immediately
easier and really rewarding to be a more
excited about each news setting you get
in cuz you like oh I get to be here now
and also it makes you more invested on
wanting to save it because you already
love it and you already love the
characters and that to me was the key
ingredient as to what made that first
game especially just really phenomenally
good and plus beyond that most of it
worked pretty dang well the combat was
pretty good the platforming in the first
game was a little man and some of the
stage layouts could have been better but
you know what that was the sort of thing
that got really refined in the second
game the second game did what I think
any good sequel should do it made the
thing it made sure to keep the things
that already worked and the things that
weren't quite there could have been
better
it didn't scrap them but it improved
them so like in the first game the gummi
ship which is your means of getting from
world to world was not a particular
highlight of the game now a lazier
developer would have scrapped that
completely they didn't they were find it
they actually made it more fun in the
second game
similarly with things like the level
layout the platforming well the
platforming general was scaled down
because they realized people were
enjoying the action the fighting a bit
more and the level layouts got better
they put a focus on what didn't work and
left what had worked alone for the most
part the story did start to get its
convoluted miss in that second game so
boy I've been kind of avoiding the story
haven't I alright so going back to the
first one it's actually while the
specifics are a little bit yeah fantasy
whatever the fantasy equivalent of
technobabble is it's really easy just to
get the gist of it there's this darkness
there's these things called the
heartless they are little black blobby
kind of things they're bad we fight them
I mean that that's it there's more going
on the the bridge between worlds you
know that there is an explanation for
that we have Disney Disney Villains
teaming up you know that that all
factors in but the ultimate core pitch
is see those little black things they're
bad deal with them cool the specifics
I'm not going to say they don't matter
but the fact that they are a little bit
not always fitting together together
isn't a detriment because the core idea
is so basic and simple what we got -
well yeah basic and somewhat simple and
clean how about that should have just
said that should backed up and edit it
in as if I said that the first time
didn't moving on so then we get to the
second one and we get the introduction
of things like organization 13 which
apparently has gotten way more
convoluted because I guess like I tried
to do a vague catch up on what's been
going on with this plot now that the new
ones out and apparently the organization
13 and Kingdom Hearts 2 isn't the
quote-unquote real organization 13
and there's another one and I I can't
even anyways they introduce something in
addition to the Heartless they
introduced the nobodies which are
basically white heartless now story-wise
it is starting to get a little bit ya
over complicated but it is still
ultimately pretty good in terms of
keeping it simple enough that when you
are dropped into a situation you know
what's going on you dropped in and go oh
there's some heartless we can kill them
Oh nobody's those are new but they're
white they're also easily identifiable
we kill them too cool and again you move
forward on that basis and the second one
had better graphics you know more
refined combat and all this stuff that I
just I just love and the original core
group of three characters Sora Riku
Kairi their dynamic and their chemistry
is I mean a little bit simplistic but
they're young characters and so it's a
very basic dynamic that I think works
and the chemistry between the characters
is pretty good and then you've got your
primary support characters which are
Donald and Goofy and obviously again
you've got the built-in rapport and
connection between those characters and
that's just a lot of fun and again it
does help with the emotional commitment
it helps that again in that first game
Riku Sora and Kyrie are basically the
only characters who are not
pre-established aren't from Final
Fantasy or aren't from Disney I haven't
really mentioned the Final Fantasy
characters too much it's because they're
just kind of there they're just kind of
dropped in
there's no visiting a final fantasy
world or a setting you just run into
characters like squall and heiress and
things like that
but by only having the new characters be
those three it meant that there was a
proper focus on them and allowed you to
get invested in them and again to care
about them now I mentioned I play chain
of Memories which was a Game Boy Advance
game and it's it has a plot function
like it technically falls between one
and two
but it's really just a rehash of one in
a 2d setting with a different core
gameplay mechanic which was kind of
cards based and it was fun enough I
enjoyed it
but it really is these first two games
that stand out in my mind and as things
built again a lot of it having to do
with the things they pull from Disney as
things built and you start and when you
go against some of these villains
because there's some that you're like
whether the fight is hard or not there's
something you're like oh yeah I can take
this like Captain Hook that fights
actually really annoying but you know
what I can take Captain Hook I can deal
with that um but then there's Ursula the
massive version of Ursula oh okay
Maleficent that's obviously there's
gonna be tough and then there was the
one that they pulled out of there but
that didn't even occur to me that could
show up um I think this was in the
second game but I remember having a
heart attack when Chernabog the demon
from the Night on Bald Mountain sequence
from Fantasia showed up and I yeah I
just about drop dead going Oh God
and again perfectly banking off of my
established understanding of what this
thing was because normally pulling that
kind of we never really even hinted that
this thing was in here big boss monster
in say on Final Fantasy game or any
other RPG would have annoyed me cuz like
it's just a big thing that I'm gonna
have to whale away at for a long time
did whatever but no I saw that and I was
terrified and the thing is these games
are by no means flawless I mean even the
second one which as I say is a more
refined experience and I think overall a
better one it does have a lot of little
things that could have been better the
thing that will always wish was that it
was possible to take direct control of
your AI partners usually being Donald
and Goofy but when you go to different
roles you can swap in other ones whoever
is relevant to that world and I remember
just getting really annoyed that you
know and you can set and
week you know what it is they do under
certain circumstances kind of like wait
what final fantasy 12 did accept that at
least in 12 if you wanted to say heck
with it and do it yourself
you could take over that character and
tell them what to do directly and you
can't in Kingdom Hearts and I kind of
wish you could so I you know there's
little things like that and like even by
the second one the plot was starting to
get a little bit I'm sorry
especially which is weird because the
core appeal is so basic it's weird that
the plot got so weird so overdone and I
know I'm a lot more nit picky about this
franchise then I usually am want to talk
about why it's awesome but the thing is
that poor idea of taking me from world
to world to world these worlds that I
love even the newer ones like I thought
it was really cool to go into into the
Pirates of the Caribbean world because
that franchise hadn't had been banged
into death into the ground yet I just
had so much fun dwelling in playing in
and saving these worlds that I had an
inherent investment in and that core
idea honestly it papers over a lot of
sins and generally want to have
something on why it's awesome I just
talk about all the things that are
amazing and again there's plenty of
stuff that's amazing in here it's fun to
play the characters are good the I
actually really like the music I can
actually like the theme song from to
sanctuary a little bit better than
simple and clean but they're both great
and I have been nitpicking but the
things that are good in this franchise
or at least the chunks of the franchise
I played is so good that I don't care
about the rest all that much I can
recognize it and in the moment sometimes
I can even go didn't need that but you
know what within a few seconds I'm I'm
running through the pride lands and sore
has been transformed into a lion and I
couldn't be happier so as much as I
could I can I can honestly even these
these first two I can nitpick them to
death
I don't want to cuz there's so much fun
and they tap into something just so core
to me cuz I never grow out of Disney
movies you know they're what there were
some that I did deliberately skip but
like I was still voluntarily watching
Disney movies well into high school I
wasn't necessarily telling my friends
that I was doing that but it was because
I loved that stuff and to have something
just tap into my love of this thing and
use it to motivate me through a game it
was an amazing experience and it's one
I'm always gonna treasure even though I
have dropped off the series and I don't
know if I'll ever play three but the
ones that I've played gave me some of my
favorite gaming experiences on an
emotional level which I talked about
what gave me sometimes journey was an
amazing emotional game for me which you
know one of my more recent gaming
experiences and this is a very different
thing from that but it just knew how to
tap in exactly into this right thing and
I think that's why it connects as well
as it does it's not because it's the
most polished or flawless game series in
the world it's definitely not but for
the people that it connects with on the
level that it connects with me man
there's really nothing else like it
Kingdom Hearts as franchise in general
for me one and two specifically that's
why I think it's awesome what are your
thoughts on this you can talk about just
the first two you can talk about the
newer stuff that I didn't bring up cuz I
played you if you're playing the new one
talk about that whatever you think about
any of this
drop something out in the comments let's
talk about it whole bunch of other stuff
you can do down there because there's
buttons and links there's a link to the
patreon it support is appreciated thank
you but there's other stuff as well my
p.o box is down there there's links to
other things that I have done or am
involved in and yo check them out but
only if you like it cuz if you don't
that is okay at the end of the day
you're the council and I'm just one of
the meetings until next time this
council is adjourned